( noises)
That's what the sound is when
the joke goes over your head.
Welcome everybody,
today we're going to review
some people that just don't get it.
Sometimes, humour can just be too
intelligent
for people to understand,
is probably especially you!
(USA Anthem in background)
My fellow nine-year-old.
(PewDiePie reading)
Guessing what people say
So, what's your talent?
It's kind of mixed a bit.
I think the middle part should be on top
YES!
I feel like it's my favorite thing to be ironically this guy,
but you know, it's not ironic
which is what makes it so good.
You can-
Smooch*
You can taste how stupid he is. It's wonderful
(PewDiePie starts reading)
9/10 redditors are [Removed] morons.
I'm glad to be the 1%
(Insecure Chuckles of Self-Realization)
1/10
(PewDiePie stops reading, starts mocking)
It's 10%
The joke went right over your head didn't it well done
I feel like this is my comments a lot of the times I gotta say
Why does everyone type r/woooosh whenever I correct their stupidity with all the recent?
True as success as Trump's has had lately. This is what liberal is now complaining about
The joke here is of course that there hasn't been enough Shrek films during the trump administration
This to me is not a joke. This is not a whoosh. This is a
whoosh
(Realizes he couldn't come up with a joke in time because he is not creative and that he gets all his comedic credit from his fans and editors)
Why am I uploading videos? Yeah, I'm in a gang
guys
that
Go
to school everyday
Hmm I don't think they quite know what an acronym is you see I am
2008 IQ intellect points
I know
Exactly. What an acronym is stupid sonic fans not being intellectuals like me
Leg day is the best day
What legs?
that's funny because I won the
Powerlifting squad competition two years in a row the second 24 year old to ever squat over
500 so I'm not really sure what your meaning my legs are 18 inches around
I think you realize I think you watch me when I do not see this giant swoll legs
They so big they so large your insults doesn't work on me. I was making a camo joke. Oh
(Sneezes all over his screen, oh wait that's his laugh)
(Gasps for Content)
The good old camo joke. It's too funny any time I wear camo and someone makes a camo joke is like oh
I already know, this is gonna be good, found dead this morning r.i.p. Steve Jobs CEO of Google, that's not him
(Slave owner clapping)
You telling me that's not Steve Jobs the CEO of Google quoted from Bob Marley, What
This is basically your comments, I just realize I'm reading my own comments here do you browse reddit and why?
No, I have never been on reddit might try it out one day, but you just reply to me on reddit (Checkmate)
Oh
It's another acronym. Yes. I Vape return my library books on time
This isn't even an acronym that's a joke congrats? Thank you for making me explain the joke well done
512 gigabyte ram. Yes. Now I can finally open three tabs in Chrome.
I can- (Breaks down in laughter as they make fun of mental disability
I Can open over 100 tabs with 16 gigabyte LC Bram. Oh
Well, well done well, you can't understand a simple joke though
congratulation VROOM
You got wooooshed bi-
I feel like a car needs to hit these people
(That's called Wishing death on someone)
As fast as the joke goes over their head
(Felix is a psychopath this is not a joke call help)
Gays in Syria [Removed] it was removed. What was it?
Holy
Africa by Toto was so popular. They named an entire
Continent after it. Excuse me. They named a 36 year-old son after a
7.5 million year-old continent named some few millennium ago
Nice one. This is
Annoying. I'm just annoyed by these the problem with quotes found on the Internet is that they are often not true
Abraham Lincoln
Well, this couldn't be a quote from him. There was no internet back there (Realizes grammar mistake but corrects himself to say) Ben
When will TED himself?
Finally show up to the talk the final boss you guys know TED talk stands for Technology Entertainment and design talks
Right. I will not let Ted hide behind these lies
any longer
Say what you want, about World War two, but whoever killed Hitler is my hero a true inspiration
But he killed himself
Maybe you should too Jesus Christ.
I don't understand how anyone can joke about something like this, okay?
(Meanwhile thinks kids should be sent to an island to reenact minecraft hunger games)
This is the kind of like I see this a lot recently memes
memes people
I don't know if people are just dumb or if they're purposely choosing to meme the meme because you can't meme a meme
The meme is a meme itself. The meme here is that Thanos came from fortnite
But this guy is trying to meme it the opposite you can't steal a meme to meme it annoys me stop it
Running was invented in
1748 by Thomas running
You guys heard about this we heard about Thomas running when he tried to walk twice at the same time
Running is in our DNA. Ok. Nobody invented it. Ok, cave men and ran to and from pray
What's next John Smith invented chewing? get that BS out of here!
I can't tell that people are you know willfully ignorant that people are memeing
Because they want so desperately to be there. Haha. Got you now guy
You know what? I mean? Why are so many people dumb? I feel really smart going through this suburb
Muslims in the USA removed
did anyone see the joke before it got deleted full here me and
Intellectual this guy is clearly memeing as well. Right? There's no whoosh here. This is a whoosh ception everybody. Well done
Shower thoughts
Walking three miles per hour. It's calming and
Enjoyable but driving 3 miles per hour. That's just aggravating and painful
Excuse me, driving 30 miles per hour. It's calming and enjoyable but walking 30 miles per hour is
aggravating and
Painful as well
Yeah
But walking at 30 miles per hour is not possible
You know what just went past you 30 miles per hour push the joke. That's right
Everybody you idiot you dummy you dumb ball dumb bang dumb the schmuck dumb me bump D bump bump
You bump
Binary and non-binary are both have asked
I don't even know why I waste my time doing that people struggle with it
So it's not half as as your transphobic post is trying to imply this post was about programming
Sometimes I just remember the fact that in French
Pen or pain means bread and it makes me think about this picture a lie
Anyone else see the sad face though, huh? Anyone spotted the sad face? Haha. You're right. I should have made a joke about that
What a perfect opportunity just missed Thank You little baby dare
Huh, I can't believe he didn't notice the face before posting it I think it was such sarcasm
I think that was sarcasm too. This may be some sort of wooshception
woo whoosh oosh
Whooshing sure is fun. I'm having a blast whooshing people
Felis you got a $5 to spend on the perfect girl 300 attract 150 cute
$2 looks like the Waluigi $3 acts like why Waluigi hundred dollars loyal?
Except for girls are living breathing things that you can't buy not to mention
We're all beautiful regardless of our variations in our personalities and appearances
Well .......
Misogynist here as long as you look like while Waluigi I'm all aboard
That makes me an IQ test before you get to go on reddit oh my god
That was the most reddit thing I've ever said
Petition to hire 1 million people to put their fingers in the shoot hole of people's guns, so they can't shoot them
It's still going to shoot. No the finger box the bullet we can do this
This is a gun we're talking about the projectile is fired using
Explosion not by compressed air open toy gun, the finger blocks it
Their finger won't block it. The shaft is only there to keep the bullets straight
No, the bullet will go forward a little
It's really not that hard to understand basic physics. Go back to school Doh Mozilla
Adults your bunger. I
Am signing this petition right now who would win a stick vs
1000 US Marines tough choice all it is is one marine to break the stick
seriously, what the f
Then you have two sticks
Stick win every time you hear the one about the airplane. No, yeah
It probably go over your head
I'm pretty smart. Try me
Thank you guys for watching another episode of woosh this is the first one out of
This is it. This is literally it if any of these jokes went over your head vaga news for you
You have to leave a like on this video right now
Pewdiepie with the 6-0 M
Taking over YouTube
Tryna get like him
Brofist to the face
Can you keep up with the pace?
And i’m never gonna switch
BUT CAN YOU DO THIS???
How’s it going bros?
Gotta get it like this
When you wanna hit the flow
Grinding like open up pop a top and never stop
Run up in the city and i’m never gonna flop
Tell me when to go i’m like whenever
I’m done with this pass the mic to Edgar